welcome back to cbs morning's first on
cbs we're talking to the mother of ahmad
arberry her name is wanda cooper jones
as jury selection begins in the trial of
three men accused of killing her son
gregory mcmichael his son travis
mcmichael and william roddy brian are
facing state charges including murder
false imprisonment and aggravated
assault
arberry was running on the street when
the defendants chased him in their
trucks he was jogging through the
neighborhood and travis mcmichael shot
him three times the defendants have all
pleaded not guilty travis mcmichael
argues that he shot the 25 year old mod
arberry in self-defense they claim that
they were justified in chasing arberry
because they thought he was a burglar
wander cooper jones joins us from
outside the courthouse in brunswick
georgia good morning to you wanda cooper
jones it's really good to see you i'm so
sorry it's under these circumstances
but i i read that you are certainly
going to be in court today and that
you're planning to go to court every day
how are you preparing yourself for this
moment and what does it mean to you
um this day means a lot to me i'm
thinking back and when a mob but first
was first killed um
we went through three prosecutors we
went through
new arrests
and we finally made it this far so this
morning i'm very grateful
yeah if there hadn't been that cell
phone video and and those huge protests
we might not have had charges in this
case
because that is correct i think without
that um video we wouldn't have the rest
but
i thank god that the the video came and
we got a rest and now we we're here to
select the jury
to finally get justice for a mind
you know we should point out that your
son was doing nothing wrong the
videotape showed that he had wandered in
the construction site he left there was
nothing was taken he had committed no
crime and travis mcmichael is claiming
self-defense in this case
saying ahmad aarberry was the aggressor
here what do you say about that
i haven't watched the video in the
entirety
but i have family members and also my my
attorney
and everyone that that has watched the
video simply says that ahmad was not
doing anything wrong
my mom was approached
amon had the choice to either fight
um
first he ran and then he had no option
but but to fight and unfortunately ahmad
was killed in the midst of that fight
you know this case is about the murder
of your son but for so many people this
is a case about race relations in the
south do you see it that way
i do think that ahmad was murdered
because he was black
um he was dragging through but
predominantly white neighborhood and he
was targeted
you know
there's a lot of
chatter about what the jury should look
like do you believe that you can get a
fair and impartial jury in that area
when there's been so much publicity in
the case are you worried about that
yes i have my concerns being that the
jurors will be picked from this
community
there has been lots of miscommunications
in the in the beginning or what happened
on that day but hopefully that we'll get
the right people in the right place to
make the right decision
what's your message to the jurors ms
cooper jones
i didn't get that question i'm sorry i'm
sorry what is what is your message to
the jurors
she can't she can't answer that
she can't answer that i hear lee merritt
your attorney sitting beside you
yes all right all right
i hear you i hear it before you go i'm
always struck every time i see a picture
of your son he looks so much like you
that you all smile alike he has the
shape of your face what would you like
us to know and remember about him on
this day
ahmad just wasn't a jogger that was
jogging in a neighborhood in south
georgia my mom was actually my son
ahmad was loved
and ahmad was loved by many
yes he certainly was wanda cooper jones
we thank you for joining us today i know
it's a difficult day for you we thank
you and we are all watching